[Music]
i suppose you will be getting away
pretty soon
now full term is over professor said a
person
not in the story to the professor of
ontography
soon after they had sat down next to
each other at a feast in the hospitable
hall of saint james's college
the professor was young neat and precise
in speech
yes he said my friends have been making
me take up golf this term
and i mean to go to the east coast in
point of fact to bernstow
i dare say you know it for a week or ten
days to improve my game
i hope to get off tomorrow o'parkins
said his neighbor on the other side if
you are going to bernstow
i wish you would look at the sight of
the templar's preceptory
and let me know if you think it would be
any good to have a dig there in the
summer
it was as you might suppose a person of
antiquarian pursuits who said this
but since he merely appears in this
prologue there is no need to give his
entitlements
certainly said parkins the professor if
you will describe to me whereabouts the
site is
i will do my best to give you an idea of
the lie of the land when i get back
or i could write to you about it if you
would tell me where you were likely to
be
don't trouble to do that thanks it's
only that i'm thinking of taking my
family in that direction in the long
and it occurred to me that as very few
of the english preceptories have ever
been properly planned
i might have an opportunity of doing
something useful on off days
the professor rather sniffed at the idea
that planting out a preceptory could be
described as useful
his neighbor continued the site i doubt
if there's anything showing above ground
must be down quite close to the beach
now the sea has encroached tremendously
as you know
all along that bit of coast i should
think from the map
that it must be about three quarters of
a mile from the globe inn
at the north end of the town where are
you going to stay
well at the globe inn as a matter of
fact said parkins
i have engaged a room there i couldn't
get in anywhere else
most of the lodging houses are shut up
in winter it seems
and as it is they tell me that the only
room of any size i can have is really a
double-bedded one
and that they haven't a corner in which
to store the other bed and so on
but i must have a fairly large room for
i'm taking some books down and mean to
do a bit of work
and though i don't quite fancy having an
empty bed not to speak of two
in what i may call for the time being my
study i suppose i can manage to rough it
for the short time i shall be there
do you call having an extra bed in your
room roughing it parkins
said a bluff person opposite look here i
shall come down and occupy it for a bit
it'll be company for you
the professor quivered but managed to
laugh in a courteous manner
by all means rogers there's nothing i
should like better
but i'm afraid you would find it rather
dull you don't play golf do you
no thank heaven said rude mr rogers
well you see when i'm not writing i
shall most likely be out on the links
and that as i say would be rather dull
for you i'm afraid
oh i don't know there's certain to be
somebody i know in the place
but of course if you don't want me speak
the word parkins
i shan't be offended truth as you always
tell us
is never offensive parkins was indeed
scrupulously polite and strictly
truthful
it is to be feared that mr rogers
sometimes practiced upon his knowledge
of these characteristics
in parkins breast there was a conflict
now raging
which for a moment or two did not allow
him to answer
that interval being over he said well if
you want the exact truth rogers
i was considering whether the room i
speak of would really be large enough to
accommodate us both comfortably
and also whether mind i shouldn't have
said this if you hadn't pressed me
you would not constitute something in
the nature of a hindrance to my work
rogers laughed loudly well done parkins
he said it's all right i promise not to
interrupt your work
don't you disturb yourself about that no
i won't come if you don't want me
but i thought i should do so nicely to
keep the ghosts off
here he might have been seen to wink and
to nudge his next neighbor
parkins might also have been seen to
become pink
i beg pardon parkins rogers continued i
ought to have said that
i forgot you didn't like levity on these
topics
well parkins said as you have mentioned
the matter i freely own that i do not
like careless talk
about what you call ghosts a man in my
position
he went on raising his voice a little
cannot i find be too careful about
appearing to sanction the current
beliefs on such subjects
as you know rogers or as you ought to
know for i think i have never concealed
my views
no you certainly have not old man put in
roger's sadovace
i hold that any semblance any appearance
of concession to the view that such
things might exist
is to me a renunciation of all that i
hold most sacred
but i'm afraid i have not succeeded in
securing your attention
your undivided attention was what dr
blimber actually
said rogers interrupted with every
appearance of an earnest desire
for accuracy but i beg your pardon
parkins
i'm stopping you no not at all
said parkins i don't remember blimber
perhaps he was before my time
but i needn't go on i'm sure you know
what i mean
yes yes said rogers rather hastily just
so
we'll go into it fully at bernstow or
somewhere
in repeating the above dialogue i have
tried to give the impression which it
made on me
that parkins was something of an old
woman rather hen-like
perhaps in his little ways totally
destitute
alas of the sense of humor but at the
same time
dauntless and sincere in his convictions
and a man deserving of the greatest
respect
whether or not the reader has gathered
so much that was the character which
parkins had
on the following day parkins did as he
had hoped
succeed in getting away from his college
and then arriving at bernstein
he was made welcome at the globe inn was
safely installed in the large
double-bedded room of which we have
heard
and was able before retiring duress to
arrange his materials for work in
apple pie order upon a commodious table
which occupied the outer end of the room
and was surrounded on three sides by
windows looking out seaward
that is to say the central window looked
straight out to sea
and those on the left and right
commanding prospects along the shore to
the north and south respectively
on the south you saw the village of
bernstow
on the north no houses were to be seen
but only the beach and the low cliff
backing it
immediately in front was a strip not
considerable
of rough grass dotted with old anchors
cap stands and so forth
then a broad path then the beach
whatever may have been the original
distance between the globe inn and the
sea
not more than 60 yards now separated
them
the rest of the population of the inn
was of course a golfing one
and included few elements that call for
a special description
the most conspicuous figure was perhaps
that of an ancient militare
secretary of london club and possessed
of a voice of incredible strength
and views of a pronouncedly protestant
type
these were apt to find utterance after
his attendance upon the ministrations of
the vicar
an estimable man with inclinations
towards a picturesque ritual which he
galutly kept down as far as he could
out of deference to east anglian
tradition
professor parkins one of whose principal
characteristics was pluck
spent the greater part of the day
following his arrival in bernstein
in what he had called improving his game
in company with this colonel wilson
and during the afternoon whether the
process of improvement were to blame or
not
i'm not sure the colonel's demeanor
assumed a coloring so lurid that even
parkins jibbed at the thought of walking
home with him from the links
he determined after a short and furtive
look at that bristling mustache and
those incarnadined features
that it would be wiser to allow the
influences of tea and tobacco to do what
they could with the colonel
before the dinner hour should render a
meeting inevitable
i might walk home tonight along the
beach he reflected
yes and take a look there will be enough
light for that
at the ruins of which disney was talking
i don't exactly know where they are by
the way
but i expect i can hardly help stumbling
on them
this he accomplished i may say in the
most literal sense
for in picking his way from the links to
the shingle beach
his foot caught partly in a gorse route
and partly in a biggish stone
and over he went when he got up and
surveyed his surroundings
he found himself in a patch of somewhat
broken ground
covered with small depressions and
mounds these latter when he came to
examine them
proved to be simply masses of flints
embedded in mortar
and grown over with turf he must he
quite rightly concluded
beyond the site of the preceptory he had
promised to look at
it seemed not unlikely to reward the
spate of the explorer
enough of the foundations was probably
left at no great depth to throw a good
deal of light on the general plan
he remembered vaguely that the templars
to whom this site had belonged
were in the habit of building round
churches and he thought a particular
series of the humps or mounds near him
did appear to be arranged in something
of a circular form
few people can resist the temptation to
try a little amateur research
in a department quite outside their own
if only for the satisfaction of showing
how successful they would have been had
they only taken it up seriously
our professor however if he felt
something of this mean desire
was also truly anxious to oblige mr
disney
so he paced with care the circular area
he had noticed
and wrote down its rough dimensions in
his pocketbook
then he proceeded to examine an oblong
eminence which lay east of the center of
the circle
and seemed to his thinking likely to be
the base of a platform or altar
at one end of it the northern a patch of
the turf was gone
removed by some boy or other creature
fairy naiturae
it might he thought be as well to probe
the soil here for evidences of masonry
and he took out his knife and began
scraping away the earth
and now followed another little
discovery a portion of soil fell inward
as he scraped and disclosed a small
cavity he lighted one match after
another
to help him to see of what nature the
hole was but the wind was too strong for
them all
by tapping and scratching the sides with
his knife however
he was able to make out that it must be
an artificial hole in masonry
it was rectangular and the sides top and
bottom
if not actually plastered were smooth
and regular
of course it was empty no as he withdrew
the knife he heard a metallic clink
and when he introduced his hand it met
with a cylindrical object
lying on the floor of the hole naturally
enough he picked it up
and when he brought it into the light
now fast fading
he could see that it too was of man's
making a metal tube
about four inches long and evidently of
some considerable age
by the time perkins had made sure that
there was nothing else in this odd
receptacle
it was too late and too dark for him to
think of undertaking any further search
what he had done had proved so
unexpectedly interesting
that he determined to sacrifice a little
more of the daylight on the morrow to
archaeology
the object which he now had safe in his
pocket was bound to be of some slight
value at least he felt sure
bleak and solemn was the view on which
he took a last look before starting
homeward
a faint yellow light in the west showed
the links on which a few figures moving
towards the clubhouse were still visible
the squat martello tower the lights of
aldzy village
the pale ribbon of sands intersected at
intervals by black wooden groinings
the dim and murmuring sea the wind was
bitter from the north but was at his
back when he set out for the globe
he quickly rattled and clashed through
the shingle and gained the sand
upon which but for the groinings which
had to be got over
every few yards the going was both good
and quiet
one last look behind to measure the
distance he had made since leaving the
ruined templars church
showed him a prospect of company on his
walk
in the shape of a rather indistinct
personage in the distance
who seemed to be making great efforts to
catch up with him
but made little if any progress i mean
that there was an appearance of running
about his movements
but that the distance between him and
parkins did not seem materially to
lessen
so at least parkins thought and decided
that he almost certainly did not know
him
and that it would be absurd to wait
until he came up
for all that company he began to think
would really be very welcome on that
lonely shore if only you could choose
your companion
in his unenlightened days he had read of
meetings in such places which even now
would hardly bear thinking of
he went on thinking of them however
until he reached home
and particularly of one which catches
most people's fancy at some time of
their childhood
now i saw in my dream that christian had
gone but a very little way
when he saw a foul fiend coming over the
field to meet him
what should i do now he thought if i
looked back and caught sight of a black
figure
sharply defined against the yellow sky
and saw that it had horns and wings
i wonder whether i should stand or run
for it
luckily the gentleman behind is not of
that kind
and he seems to be about as far off now
as when i saw him first
well at this rate he won't get his
dinner as soon as i shall
and dear me it's within a quarter of an
hour of the time now
i must run perkins had in fact
very little time for dressing when he
met the colonel at dinner
peace or as much of her as that
gentleman could manage
reigned once more in the military bosom
nor was she put to flight in the hours
of bridge that followed dinner
for parkins was a more than respectable
player
when therefore he retired towards 12
o'clock
he felt that he had spent his evening in
quite a satisfactory way
and that even for so long as a fortnight
or three weeks
life at the globe would be supportable
under similar conditions
especially thought he if i go on
improving my game
as he went along the passages he met the
boots of the globe
who stopped and said beg your pardon sir
but as i was abrushing your coat just
now there was something fell out of the
pocket
i put it on your chest of drawer sir in
your room sir
a piece of a pipe or something of that
sir thank you sir
you'll find it on your chest or drawers
sir yes sir
good night sir the speech served to
remind perkins of his little discovery
of that afternoon
it was with some considerable curiosity
that he turned it over by the light of
his candles
it was of bronze he now saw and was
shaped very much after the manner of the
modern dog whistle
in fact it was yes certainly it was
actually no more nor less than a whistle
he put it to his lips but it was quite
full of a fine caked up sand or earth
which would not yield to knocking but
must be loosened with a knife
tidy as ever in his habits parkins
cleared out the earth onto a piece of
paper
and took the ladder to the window to
empty it out
the night was clear and bright as he saw
when he had opened the casement
and he stopped for an instant to look at
the sea and note a belated wanderer
stationed on the shore in front of the
inn then he shut the window
a little surprised at the late hours
people kept at bernstein
and took his whistle to the light again
why
surely there were marks on it and not
merely marks but letters
a very little rubbing rendered the
deeply cut inscription quite legible
but the professor had to confess after
some earnest thought
that the meaning of it was as obscure to
him as the writing on the wall to
belshazzar
there were legends both on the front and
on the back of the whistle
the one read thus fur
the other quiz est ista
qui bennett i ought to be able to make
it out he thought
but i suppose i am a little rusty in my
latin
when i come to think of it i don't
believe i even know the word for a
whistle
the long one does seem simple enough it
ought to mean
who is this who is coming well the best
way to find out is evidently to whistle
for him
he blew tentatively and stopped suddenly
startled and yet pleased at the note he
had elicited
it had a quality of infinite distance in
it and soft as it was
he somehow felt it must be audible for
miles round
it was a sound too that seemed to have
the power which many sense possess
of forming pictures in the brain he saw
quite clearly for a moment a vision of a
wide dark expanse at night
with a fresh wind blowing and in the
midst a lonely figure
how employed he could not tell perhaps
he would have seen more had not the
picture been broken by the sudden surge
of a gust of wind against his casement
so sudden that it made him look up just
in time to see the white glint of a
seabird's wing
somewhere outside the dark panes the
sound of the whistle had so
fascinated him that he could not help
trying it once more
this time more boldly the note was
little
if at all louder than before and
repetition broke the illusion
no picture followed as he had half hoped
it might
but what is this goodness what force the
wind can get up in a few minutes
what a tremendous gust there i knew that
window fastening was no use
i thought so both candles out it's
enough to tear the room to pieces
the first thing was to get the window
shut while you might count
20 parkins was struggling with a small
casement and felt almost as if he were
pushing back a sturdy burglar
so strong was the pressure it slackened
at once and the window banged too and
latched itself
now to relight the candles and see what
damage if any had been done
no nothing seemed to miss no glass even
was broken in the casement
but the noise had evidently roused at
least one member of the household
the colonel was to be heard stumping in
his stockinged feet on the floor
above and growling quickly as it had
risen
the wind did not fall at once on it went
moaning and rushing past the house at
times rising to a cry so desolate
that his parkins disinterestedly said it
might have made fanciful people feel
quite uncomfortable
even the unimaginative he thought after
a quarter of an hour
might be happier without it whether it
was the wind or the excitement of golf
or of the researches and the preceptory
that kept parkins awake he was not sure
awake he remained in any case long
enough to fancy
as i am afraid i often do myself under
such conditions
that he was a victim of all manner of
fatal disorders
he would lie counting the beats of his
heart convinced that it was going to
stop work every moment
and would entertain grave suspicions of
his lungs brain liver etc
suspicions which he was sure would be
dispelled by the return of daylight
but which until then refused to be put
aside
he found a little vicarious comfort in
the idea that someone else was in the
same boat
a near neighbor in the darkness it was
not easy to tell his direction
was tossing and rustling in his bed too
the next stage was that parkins shut his
eyes and determined to give sleep every
chance
here again over excitement asserted
itself in another form
that of making pictures experto crade
pictures do come to the closed eyes of
one trying to sleep
and often his pictures are so little to
his taste that he must open his eyes and
disperse the images
parkinson's experience on this occasion
was a very distressing one
he found that the picture which
presented itself to him was continuous
when he opened his eyes of course it
went but when he shut them once more it
framed itself afresh
and acted itself out again neither
quicker nor slower than before what he
saw
was this a long stretch of shore
shingle edged by sand and intersected at
short intervals with black groins
running down to the water
a scene in fact so like that of his
afternoon's walk
that in the absence of any landmark it
could not be distinguished there from
the light was obscure conveying an
impression of gathering storm
late winter evening and slight cold rain
on this bleak stage at first no actor
was visible
then in the distance a bobbing black
object appeared
a moment more and it was a man running
jumping
clambering over the groins and every few
seconds
looking eagerly back the nearer he came
the more obvious
it was that he was not only anxious but
even terribly frightened
though his face was not to be
distinguished he was moreover
almost at the end of his strength on he
came
each successive obstacle seemed to cause
him more difficulty than the last
will he get over this next one thought
parkins it seems a little higher than
the others
yes half climbing half throwing himself
he did get over
and fell all in a heap on the other side
the side nearest to the spectator
there as if really unable to get up
again he remained crouching under the
groin
looking up in an attitude of painful
anxiety so far
no cause whatever for the fear of the
runner had been shown
but now there began to be seen far up
the shore
a little flicker of something
light-colored moving to and fro
with great swiftness and irregularity
rapidly growing larger it too declared
itself as a figure
in pale fluttering draperies ill-defined
there was something about its motion
which made parkins very unwilling to see
it at close quarters
it would stop raise arms bow itself
toward the sand
then run stooping across the beach to
the water edge and back again
and then rising upright once more
continue its course forward
at a speed that was startling and
terrifying
the moment came when the pursuer was
hovering about from left to right
only a few yards beyond the groin where
the runner lay in hiding
after two or three ineffectual castings
hither and thither
it came to a stop stood upright with
arms raised high
and then darted straight forward towards
the groin
it was at this point that parkins always
failed in his resolution to keep his
eyes shut
with many misgivings as to incipient
failure of eyesight
overworked brain excessive smoking and
so on
he finally resigned himself to light his
candle get out a book
and pass the night waking rather than be
tormented by this persistent panorama
which he saw clearly enough could only
be a morbid reflection of his walk and
his thoughts on that very day
the scraping of match on box and the
glare of light must have startled some
creature of the night
rats or whatnot which he heard scurry
across the floor
from the side of his bed with much
rustling dear dear the match is out
full that it is but the second one burnt
better
and a candle and a book were duly
procured over which perkins poured till
sleep of a wholesome
kind came upon him and that in no long
space
for about the first time in his orderly
and prudent life
he forgot to blow out the candle and
when he was called next morning at eight
there was still a flicker in the socket
and a sad mess of guttered grease on the
top of the little table
after breakfast he was in his room
putting the finishing touches to his
golfing costume
fortune had again allotted the kernel to
him for a partner
when one of the maids came in oh if you
please
she said would you like any extra
blankets on your bed sir
ah thank you said perkins yes i think i
should like one
it seems likely to turn rather colder
in a very short time the maid was back
with the blanket
which bed should i put it on sir she
asked
what why that one the one i slept in
last night
he said pointing to it oh yes i beg your
pardon sir but you seem to have tried
both of them
least ways we had to make them both up
this morning
really how very absurd said parkins
i certainly never touched the other
except to lay some things on it
did it actually seem to have been slept
in oh yes sir said the maid
why all the things was crumpled and
throwed about always if you'll excuse me
sir
quite as if anyone hadn't passed but a
very poor night sir
dear me said parkins well i may have
disordered it more than i thought
when i unpacked my things i'm very sorry
to have given you the extra trouble i'm
sure
i expect a friend of mine soon by the
way a gentleman from cambridge to come
and occupy it for a night or two
that will be all right i suppose won't
it oh yes to be sure sir
thank you sir it's no trouble i'm sure
said the maid
and departed to giggle with her
colleagues
parkins set forth with a stern
determination to improve his game
i'm glad to be able to report that he
succeeded so far in this enterprise that
the colonel who had been rather repining
at the prospect of a second day's play
in his company
became quite chatty as the morning
advanced and his voice boomed out over
the flats
as certain also of our own minor poets
have said like some great bourdon
in a minster tower extraordinary wind
that we had last night he said
in my old home we should have said
someone had been whistling for it
should you indeed said parkins is there
a superstition of that kind still
current in your part of the country
i don't know about superstition said the
colonel they believe in it all over
denmark and norway
as well as on the yorkshire coast and my
experience is mind you
that there's generally something at the
bottom of what these country folk hold
to
and have held to for generations but
it's your drive
or whatever it might have been the
golfing reader will have to imagine
appropriate digressions at the proper
intervals
when conversation was resumed parkins
said with a slight hesitancy
apropos of what you were saying just now
colonel i think i ought to tell you that
my own views on such subjects
are very strong i am in fact a convinced
disbeliever
in what is called the supernatural what
said the colonel do you mean to tell me
you don't believe in second side or
ghosts or anything of that kind
in nothing whatever of that kind
returned perkins firmly
well said the colonel but it appears to
me at that rate sir that you must be
little better than a sadducee
parkins was on the point of answering
that in his opinion the statuses were
the most sensible persons he had ever
read of in the old testament
but feeling some doubt as to whether
much mention of them was to be found in
that work
he preferred to laugh the accusation off
perhaps i am
he said but here give me my clique boy
excuse me one moment colonel a short
interval
now as to whistling for the wind let me
give you my theory about it
the laws which govern winds are really
not at all perfectly known
to fisherfolk and such of course not
known at all
a man or woman of eccentric habits
perhaps or a stranger
is seen repeatedly on the beach at some
unusual hour and is heard whistling
soon afterwards a violent wind rises a
man who could read the sky perfectly or
who possessed a barometer
could have foretold that it would the
simple people of a fishing village have
no barometers
and only a few rough rules for
prophesying weather
what more natural than that the
eccentric personage i postulated should
be regarded as having raised the wind
or that he or she should clutch eagerly
at the reputation of being able to do so
now take last night's wind as it happens
i myself was whistling i blew a whistle
twice
and the wind seemed to come absolutely
in answer to my call
if anyone had seen me the audience had
been a little restive under this
harangue
and parkins had i fear fallen somewhat
into the tone of a lecturer
but at the last sentence the colonel
stopped whistling were you
he said and what sort of whistle did you
use
play the stroke first interval
about that whistle you were asking
colonel it's rather a curious one
i have it in my no i see i've left it in
my room
as a matter of fact i found it yesterday
and then
parkins narrated the manner of his
discovery of the whistle upon hearing
which the colonel grunted and opined
that in parkinson's place
he should himself be careful about using
a thing that had belonged to a set of
papists
of whom speaking generally it might be
affirmed that you never knew what they
might not have been up to
from this topic he diverged the
enormities of the vicar who had given
notice on the previous sunday
that friday would be the feast of saint
thomas the apostle
and that there would be a service at 11
o'clock in the church
this and other similar proceedings
constituted in the colonel's view
a strong presumption that the vicar was
a concealed papist if not a jesuit
and parkins who could not very readily
follow the colonel in this region
did not disagree with him in fact they
got on so well together in the morning
that there was no talk on either side of
their separating after lunch
both continued to play well during the
afternoon or at least well enough to
make them forget everything else until
the light began to fail them
not until then did parkins remember that
he had meant to do some more
investigating at the preceptory
but it was of no great importance he
reflected one day was as good as another
he might as well go home with the
colonel as they turned the corner of the
house the colonel was almost knocked
down by a boy who rushed into him at the
very top of his speed
and then instead of running away
remained hanging onto him and panting
the first words of the warrior were
naturally those of reproof and objection
but he very quickly discerned that the
boy was almost speechless with fright
inquiries were useless at first when the
boy got his breath he began to howl
and still clung to the colonel's legs he
was at last detached but continued to
howl
what in the world is the matter with you
what have you been up to what have you
seen
said the two men i've seen it wave at me
out of the window
wailed the boy and i don't like it what
window
said the irritated colonel come pull
yourself together my boy
the front window it was at the hotel
said the boy
at this point perkins was in favor of
sending the boy home but the colonel
refused
he wanted to get to the bottom of it he
said it was most dangerous to give a boy
such a fright as this one it had
and if it turned out that people had
been playing jokes they should suffer
for it in some way
and by a series of questions he made out
this story
the boy had been playing about on the
grass in front of the globe with some
others
then they had gone home to their tees
and he was just going
when he happened to look up at the front
window and see it waving at him
it seemed to be a figure of some sort
and white as far as he knew
couldn't see its face but it waved at
him and it wasn't a right thing
not to say not a right person was there
a light in the room
no he didn't think to look if there was
a light which was the window
was it the top one or the second one the
second one it was
the big window that has two little ones
at the sides
very well my boy said the colonel after
a few more questions
you run away home now i expect it with
some person trying to give you a start
another time like a brave english boy
you just throw a stone
well no not that exactly but you go and
speak to the waiter or to mr simpson the
landlord
and yes and say that i advise you to do
so
the boy's face expressed some of the
doubt he felt as to the likelihood of mr
simpson's lending a favorable ear to his
complaint
but the colonel did not appear to
perceive this and went on
and here's a sixpence no i see it's a
shilling
and you be off home and don't think any
more about it
the youth hurried off with agitated
thanks and the colonel and parkins went
round to the front of the globe and
recon ordered
there was only one window answering to
the description that they had been
hearing
well that's curious said parkins it's
evidently my window the lad was talking
about
will you come up for a moment colonel
wilson we ought to be able to see if
anyone has been taking liberties in my
room
they were soon in the passage and made
as if to open the door
then he stopped and felt in his pockets
this is more serious than i thought
was his next remark i remember now that
before i started this morning i locked
the door
it is locked now and what is more here
is the key
and he held it up now he went on if the
servants are in the habit of going into
one's room during the day when one is
away
i can only say that well that i don't
approve of it at all
conscious of a somewhat weak climax he
busied himself in opening the door
which was indeed locked and in lighting
candles
no he said nothing seems disturbed
except your bed put in the kernel
excuse me that isn't my bed said parkins
i don't use that one
but it does look as if someone had been
playing tricks with it
it certainly did the clothes were
bundled up and twisted together
in a most tortuous fashion parkins
pondered
that must be it he said it last i
disordered the clothes last night in
unpacking and they haven't made it since
perhaps they came in to make it and that
boy saw them through the window
and then they were called away and
locked the door after them yes
i think that must be it well ring and
ask
said the colonel and this appeal to
parkins as practical
the maid appeared and to make a long
story short deposed that she had made
the bed in the morning when the
gentleman was in the room
and hadn't been there since no she
hadn't no other key
mr simpson he kept the keys he'd be able
to tell the gentleman if anyone had been
up
this was a puzzle investigation showed
that nothing of value had been taken
and parkins remembered the disposition
of the small objects on tables and so
forth well enough to be pretty sure that
no pranks had been played with them
mr and mrs simpson furthermore agreed
that neither of them had given the
duplicate key of the room to any person
whatever during the day
nor could parkins fair-minded man as he
was detect anything in the demeanor of
master mistress or maid that indicated
guilt
he was much more inclined to think that
the boy had been imposing on the colonel
the latter was unwantedly silent and
pensive at dinner
and throughout the evening when he bade
good night to parkins he murmured in a
gruff undertone
you know where i am if you want me
during the night
why yes thank you colonel wilson i think
i do but there isn't much prospect of my
disturbing you i hope
by the way he added did i show you that
old whistle i spoke of
i think not well here it is the colonel
turned it over
gingerly in the light of the candle can
you make anything of the inscription
asked parkins as he took it back no not
in this light
what do you mean to do with it oh well
when i get back to cambridge i shall
submit it to some of the archaeologists
there
and see what they think of it and very
likely if they consider it worth having
i may present it to one of the museums
said the colonel well you may be right
all i know
is that if it were mine i should chuck
it straight into the sea
it's no use talking i'm well aware but i
expect that with you it's a case of live
and learn
i hope so i'm sure and i wish you a good
night
he turned away leaving perkins an act to
speak at the bottom of the stair
and soon each was in his own bedroom
by some unfortunate accident there were
neither blinds nor curtains to the
windows of the professor's room
the previous night he had thought little
of this but tonight there seemed every
prospect of a bright moon
rising to shine directly on his bed and
probably wake him later on
when he noticed this he was a good deal
annoyed but with an ingenuity which i
can only envy
he succeeded in rigging up with the help
of a railway rug
some safety pins and a stick and
umbrella a screen
which if it only held together would
completely keep the moonlight off his
bed
and shortly afterwards he was
comfortably in that bed
when he had read a somewhat solid work
long enough to produce a decided wish
for sleep
he cast a drowsy glance around the room
blew out the candle
and fell back upon the pillow he must
have slept
soundly for an hour or more when a
sudden clatter shook him up in a most
unwelcome manner
in a moment he realized what had
happened his carefully constructed
screen had given way and a very bright
frosty moon was shining directly on his
face
this was highly annoying could he
possibly get up and reconstruct the
screen
or could he manage to sleep if he did
not
for some minutes he lay and pondered
over the possibilities
then he turned over sharply and with all
his eyes open lay breathlessly listening
there had been a movement he was sure in
the empty bed on the opposite side of
the room
tomorrow he would have it moved for
there must be rats or something
playing about in it it was quiet now
no the commotion began again there was a
rustling and shaking
surely more than any rat could cause
i can figure to myself something of the
professor's bewilderment and horror
for i have in a dream 30 years back seen
the same thing happen
but the reader will hardly perhaps
imagine how dreadful it was to him
to see a figure suddenly sit up and what
he had known was an empty bed
he was out of his own bed in one bound
and made a dash towards the window
where lay his only weapon the stick with
which he had propped his screen
this was as it turned out the worst
thing he could have done
because the personage in the empty bed
with a sudden smooth motion
slipped from the bed and took up a
position without spread arms between the
two beds
and in front of the door parkins watched
it in a horrid perplexity
somehow the idea of getting past it and
escaping through the door was
intolerable to him
he could not have borne he didn't know
why to touch it
and as for its touching him he would
sooner dash himself through the window
than have that happen
it stood for the moment in a band of
dark shadow and he had not seen what its
face was like
now it began to move in a stooping
posture
and all at once the spectator realized
with some horror
and some relief that it must be blind
for it seemed to feel about with its
muffled arms in a groping and random
fashion
turning half away from him it became
suddenly conscious of the bed he had
just left
and darted towards it and bent and felt
over the pillows in a way which made
parkins shudder as he had never in his
life thought it possible
in a very few moments it seemed to know
that the bed was empty
and then moved forward into the area of
light and facing the window
it showed for the first time what manner
of thing it was
parkins who very much dislikes being
questioned about it
did once describe something of it in my
hearing and i gathered that what he
chiefly remembers about it
is horrible an intensely horrible face
of crumpled linen
what expression he read upon it he could
not or would not tell
but that the fear of it went nigh to
maddening him as certain
but he was not at leisure to watch it
for long with formidable quickness it
moved into the middle of the room
and as it groped and waved one corner of
its draperies swept across parkinson's
face
he could not though he knew how perilous
a sound was
he could not keep back a cry of disgust
and this gave the searcher an instant
clue
it leapt towards him upon the instant
and the next moment he was halfway
through the window backwards
uttering cry upon cry at the utmost
pitch of his voice
and the linen face was thrust close into
his own
at this almost the last possible second
deliverance came
as you will have guessed the colonel
burst the door open and was just in time
to see the dreadful group at the window
when he reached the figures only one was
left
parkins sank forward into the room in a
faint and before him on the floor lay a
tumbled heap of bed clothes
colonel wilson asked no questions but
busied himself keeping everyone else out
of the room
and in getting parkins back to his bed
and himself wrapped in a rug
occupied the other bed for the rest of
the night
early on the next day rogers arrived
more welcome than he would have been a
day before
and the three of them held a very long
consultation in the professor's room
at the end of it the colonel left the
hotel door carrying a small object
between his finger and thumb
which he cast as far into the sea as a
very brawny arm could send it
later on the smoke of a burning ascended
from the back premises of the globe
exactly what explanation was patched up
for the staff and visitors at the hotel
i must confess i do not recollect the
professor was somehow cleared of the
ready suspicion of delirium tremens
and the hotel of the reputation of a
troubled house
there is not much question as to what
would have happened to parkins if the
colonel had not intervened when he did
he would either have fallen out of the
window or else lost his wits
but it is not so evident what more the
creature that came into answer to the
whistle
could have done than frighten there
seemed to be absolutely nothing material
about it
save the bed clothes of which it had
made itself a body
the colonel who remembered a not very
dissimilar occurrence in india
was of the opinion that if parkins had
closed with it it could really have done
very little
and that its one power was that of
frightening the whole thing he said
served to confirm his opinion of the
church of rome
there is really nothing more to tell but
as you may imagine the professor's views
on certain points are less clear-cut
than they used to be
his nerves too have suffered he cannot
even now
see a surplus hanging on a door quite
unmoved and the spectacle of a scarecrow
in a field
late on a winter afternoon has cost him
more than one sleepless night
you